وفي سوريا ارتفع عدد ضحايا الزلزال الذي
ضرب محافظات حلب وادلب والذي قيا وحمى
وطرطوس الى 911 قتيلا واكثر من 2400 مصاب
هذا وقد اعلنت وزاره الصحه السوريه ان عدد
قتل الزلزال بلغ 461 شخصا بينما اعلن وزير
الصحه بمناطق المعارضه ارتفاع عدد ضحايا
في شمال غربي سوريا الى 450 قتيلا اكثر من
1200 مصاب وكانت الحكومه التابعه للمعارضه
السوريه قد اعلنت ان شمال غربي سوريا اصبح
منطقه منكوبه وناشد مدير الدفاع المدني
السوري العالم الاسراعة بتقديم الدعم
والمساعدات
هذا وقد قال دفاع المدني السوري ان مئات
العائلات لا تزال تحت الانقاض وان فرقه
تواجه صعوبات في عمليات البحث والانقاذ
بسبب نقص المعدات وبث الدفاع المدني مشاهد
من عمليات البحث والانقاذ التي تقوم بها
فرقه في مدينه سلقين شمال غربي ادلب
السوريه